did i hear that you guys get credit for
listening to me speak
that's that's not right um
i wish harvard was that easy um so how
many of you guys
sorry
how many of you guys um that our
students know what you want to do with
your lives
know where you want to go not a lot so i
had no idea
but how many of you guys know that you
want to get into technology
something in tech startups and how many
of you guys in healthcare
like okay so a lot of people in tech not
a lot in healthcare
that's about what i would expect well i
work at kind of the intersection
of the two and i'm relatively new to
healthcare
unlike most people in the healthcare
space that really knew they wanted to be
doctors since they were this little if
you guys know any pre-meds
most of them you know were born knowing
they wanted to be a doctor
i'm relatively new to the healthcare
space and i hope that throughout my talk
today i can inspire some of you guys
that never thought about a career in
healthcare to maybe consider
becoming a healthcare entrepreneur so
quick background on me
born and raised in ohio any ohioans
yay i was
one of the editors and the designers of
my high school newspaper
and all kind of growing up i thought i
was going to go to new york city
and become a magazine journalist and
design magazines and do something really
creative
but life had other plans for me and
i couldn't afford to go to nyu where i
really wanted to go
and um my senior year 9 11 happened
and so i really reassessed what i was
going to do and i decided to
go to school a little bit closer to home
where i had a scholarship at case
western
at that point i didn't know what i was
going to do because my dreams of
being a fashion magazine editor were
crushed and my dad convinced me to study
finance he thought that i was okay at
math
but most importantly if i studied
finance i'd have a stable job and a 401k
and that's all he really wanted for me
so i studied finance i studied econ and
i didn't fail out
and when it came time to graduate i
didn't know what i wanted to do but i
wanted to know that i i knew that i
wanted to go
as far away as possible from ohio so
um i ended up getting a job out here at
intel
in the corporate finance department i
didn't even know what a microprocessor
chip was
at the time but i knew that california
was much better than ohio and i packed
my bags
drove cross country and i've been here
ever since except for the two years i
went back out east i enjoyed my first
job i thought it was a really great
place to launch my career
i already knew how to work i actually
had jobs since i was 15
all through high school all through
college and i think part of the battle
is just knowing how to work
how to get up every day go to the office
please a boss
keep good tabs on your colleagues so i
already knew how to work
and really it was the technical aspects
of my job that i had to learn
i was responsible for a subsec of
revenue for intel and i had to pull this
data out of one system
put it into another report and send it
to my boss and she sent it to her boss
and
her boss's boss and her boss's boss the
work was pretty tedious
and so i decided to invest in building
some macros to make my job a little bit
easier
and i was able to get my job down to i'm
not going to say because
someone from intel might be watching but
a lot less than 40 hours a week i was
able to just click a button
it pulled all the data it automatically
put it into the spreadsheet
and i had a pretty easy job so i ended
up with a lot of time on my hands
and i began doing yoga volunteering
getting to know the san francisco
nightlife scene i
met my now husband at a bar in north
beach which is no longer
in existence um and he was working at a
little startup called facebook at the
time
um and one day when i was at yoga
um i was you know had a lot of time in
my hands again um
i was looking around and the class was
half full
and there was a bunch of excess capacity
in there
and i came up with an idea i thought you
know there's
there it costs a studio just as much to
fill this class as not
and if we could make use of those extra
spaces in this class then maybe we can
do some good
and so i went down the street to ucsf's
osher cancer center and i said if i can
get you guys free yoga
are there recent cancer survivors that
are no longer eligible for your services
that we could get into these yoga
studios and
then i went to more yoga studios and
said can you give me free passes i'll
put them to use and you're not going to
fill this class up anyways
so i started doing this on the side um
and grew the organization to about 200
yoga studios that were offering free
classes across the nation
and then we started doing classes within
the clinical setting as well
and it was really cool i called it yoga
bear it's still up and running
yogabear.org
check it out so i had this day job in
corporate america that paid well but was
really boring
and then i had this side project that
was going really well that was really
interesting but most importantly really
rewarding
sorry these two kind of lives that i was
living and i did what any
you know 20 something that doesn't know
what they want to do with their lives
did
i applied to grad school and was
fortunate enough to get accepted to
harvard business school where i decided
i would figure out what the heck i
wanted to do with my life
by that point at least i knew the
direction i wanted to go in i loved
silicon valley i loved
the technology industry i love the
energy and optimism that's out here
but also through my work with yoga bear
recognized that
there was a lot of issues with our
health care system and how we define
care and how we really help people get
better
so i tried to learn as much as i could
about
this industry called mobile health and
how our phones would turn into
health care for us i was very lucky to
get an internship at apple
where they put me in charge of the
health care and medical segment
the fact that they put an intern in
charge of that segment
probably uh illustrates how the sec
the segment was doing for the app store
it wasn't that interesting uh wasn't
that profitable
um it's getting better but the the
gaming
segment the lifestyle segment the sports
segment all these other apps just had
a ton of really great products and
really great entrepreneurs that were
building
tools and the developers that i work
i was working with at the time were
mostly third-tier development shops
um overseas that hospitals or large
healthcare companies
would hire to build an app and i was
really disappointed uh
that i didn't see more great
entrepreneurs in the space
and so i came up with an idea um rock
health
which is what i'm doing now to really
inspire
and find and support great entrepreneurs
that want to take a stab at fixing some
problems in health care
so that's kind of how i got to where i
am uh and now that you know a little bit
more about me
i'd really like to spend the rest of the
time trying to convince you that
healthcare
needs your talents um if i can just get
even one of you excited about healthcare
i think
it'll be worth the rush hour drive that
i took to get here
so the healthcare system traditionally
hasn't done a great job welcoming
diverse talents into the space
the industry is full of jargon and
complexities and
it's notoriously closed hierarchical
understaffed chaotic
nothing that was appealing to me as a 19
year old and perhaps
why so few of you raised your hands
today and the healthcare industry likes
to think that it's unique it likes to
think that it's a system unlike other
systems that we experience
and it thinks it has a monopoly on
wisdom of how to
solve the problems that we face but i
like to quote albert einstein when he
said we cannot solve our problems with
the same thinking we used when we
created them
healthcare is a system and we need all
sorts of thinkers
developers designers economists system
architects
we really need even mbas to work
together to make change in the industry
i've committed my career to finding and
inspiring the best entrepreneurs who can
think differently
about the problems that we face today if
you didn't know
our health care system is a big hot mess
it's one of the largest industries in
our nation
we spend 2.7 trillion on health care in
the us alone
to put that into context does anybody
know how big the u.s advertising
industry is
it's 150 billion so the total
addressable u.s market
for twitter facebook google snapchat
is five percent of the healthcare market
so we have all these really great
entrepreneurs that are building
new ways to share photos yet that market
is only five percent
of what a market in healthcare could be
for your business so from a business
standpoint you should consider it
we have the most expensive system in the
world yet
our health outcomes and quality are no
better and often worse than other
developed nations
the national academy of sciences put a
report out last year saying that
americans are less healthy across their
entire life spans
than citizens of 16 other wealthy
nations
we live shorter lives experience more
injuries and illnesses than people in
other high-income countries
but we pay the most and as healthcare
consumers which you all
are this should make you very very mad i
can't think of another industry that's
so vital to our lives
that's so universal that touches every
one of us throughout
our entire lives that's also so broken
so to understand some of the problems
the costs
and why costs are so high and my
outcomes are so dismal
i wanted to take a few minutes to
describe
three problems that are systemic
problems in health care
the first is how we pay for health care
the second is how providers our
hospitals
price health care and the third is all
around our personal health records and
how
they don't really belong to you so let's
talk about how we pay for health care
does anybody know how we pay for
healthcare
employers yep so consumers
while we consume over 2 trillion in
health care services
we actually only pay for out of pocket
ourselves directly 12 of the health care
we consume
so when it comes to paying for health
care we as consumers expect
not to pay so who's who's paying it's
really
our employers um over the past 50 years
there have been major shifts
in who pays for healthcare and employers
are now spending 21
sorry are now paying for 21 percent of
healthcare spending
mostly via insurance premiums this
employment-based system that we've
created was not the product of a
carefully designed health policy
in a free market it was actually the
byproduct of wage controls during world
war
ii so during this time employers had a
wage freeze
and they had a ceiling on how much they
could pay employees
but there was a loophole wage controls
only accounted
for salaries employers could get
creative
and provide fringe benefits like
healthcare
and they were able to do that and
provide healthcare so they compete with
one another
and i like to think about it as like
food at google once you set the standard
that something's going to be there and
be available it's nearly impossible
to take away congress actually has
encouraged this
and they treat employment-based health
insurance as a tax-deductible business
expense
even though unfairly tax preferences are
not granted to any of you if you buy
insurance as an independent individual
so there are a couple of problems with
having employers pay for health care
problem number one is that in the long
run really just moving around dollars
that would otherwise be salaries
a healthy family that doesn't visit the
doctor more than once a year for a
checkup and doesn't have
any prescription drugs they tend to
think that they spend nothing on health
care
yet it's probably their biggest purchase
all year the average family
in their premiums exceeds 22 000 this is
the average family in 2013
spent 22 000 a year even if they only
did
one checkup and they had no prescription
drugs so it's a huge purchase
and we tend to think that we're not
paying anything when actually we really
are
the second problem with having employers
control our health care is that it's
only temporary
it's tied to a certain job at a certain
company
and once that job is no longer there for
you you lose your health care
nowhere else in the industrialized world
does a family that's already down on
their luck from losing their job
also lose their health insurance it only
happens here in america
under the employment-based health care
insurance
so the second systemic problem is really
how we price healthcare
um and this one was was really fun to
learn about uh
healthcare is not a free market the
prices are not transparent to us
unlike any other big ticket expense if
anybody's bought
a car or a house or even a haircut it's
virtually
impossible to know how much a medical
procedure costs
until you get the bill if you try
calling a hospital
and asking them how much something very
routine costs they'll tell you that
that's proprietary information
not only are healthcare prices opaque
but they're based on what hospitals
and doctors do rather than what on
patients need
what patients need in theory hospitals
determine the price of procedures using
what is called a charge master
essentially this is a database
containing all the procedures that they
perform
and the associated price however
insurance companies
they like to negotiate prices and since
they cover many many lives in a region
a hospital has little leverage if they
want to see those patients
so the only people who really end up
paying the full price that's listed on
the charge master
are those who are least able to pay the
unemployed
or the sorry the uninsured a problem
with how we price healthcare
traditionally
is that hospitals and doctors are paid
based on the volume
of procedures that they perform the fee
for service system
only creates perverse incentives
rewarding volume rather than health
outcomes
and it does little to encourage
preventative care even if it would
significantly improve a patient's
outcomes in the long run
do you think a hospital makes more money
from preventing
or treating a heart attack yes
they absolutely make way more money
treating a heart attack
than educating patients so that they
don't get that heart attack in the first
place
one of our entrepreneurs told me a story
that i really like
during the 1800s the british colonies
were sending their prisoners to
australia
and they were paying the ship captains
for every
every prisoner that would get on the
ship as you can imagine the ship
captains would then take as many
prisoners as they could
and stuff them in the ship and send them
to australia but
only about half of the prisoners were
surviving that long trip
and they thought this was a problem so
they started sending doctors on board
they started providing citrus to combat
scurvy
but nothing worked still about half of
the prisoners would die before they get
to australia
then economist edwin chadwick suggested
a change in the incentive structure for
the ship captains
instead of paying them for every
prisoner that boarded the ship
in the uk instead why not pay the ship
captains for every prisoner that got off
alive in australia
can you guess what happened survival
rates went from 50 percent to 98 percent
the moral of the story uh is that
incentives really do matter
and we've fallen into this system where
our incentives are just
completely out of whack um the third
problem
uh which is not related to
policy as much it's really around the
issue of interoperability
so a friend of mine was actually being
treated for what they thought was a
brain tumor
here at stanford hospital a few months
into her treatment she actually fell
into a coma while she was at home in san
francisco
we called an ambulance and they took her
to the nearest hospital which was ucsf
um and it was a friday now ucsf and
stanford are really the two leading
hospitals in the world
they're 35 miles from each other in the
heart of silicon valley
in the innovation epicenter of the world
and in 2012 ucsf spent 160 million
dollars
on a new medical record system with a
company in this space called
epic stanford actually uses that same
exact software to manage the medical
records
on their campus despite all of this
ucsf was unable to obtain her medical
files
outlining her condition her latest mri
results and other health details
for four days it was the weekend and
there was no human being
to transfer this vital information 35
miles
ucsf had no choice but to run the test
again
i tell this story because a lot of the
problems in healthcare
are not technology problems i wish they
were technology problems because there
are a lot of really smart technologists
but the technology to remotely share
health records is not novel
it's not a groundbreaking technology
it's a systemic problem
we treat medical records as though they
were stanford's property
not the patient's property there was no
financial disincentive or penalty
for stanford not to share those records
and ucsf
actually made more money by being able
to run those tests again
there is an incentive problem for
providers not to be
interoperable and that's truly a market
failure
i could go on and on and on and on
listing all of the problems in this mess
that we've inherited
the healthcare system simply doesn't
work and we all have a responsibility to
fix it
so let's talk about some of the people
in the companies that are doing just
that through my work at rock health over
the past couple of years
we've funded almost 60 companies working
in digital health
we look for entrepreneurs from inside or
outside the healthcare system who are
working on software and hardware
solutions that will transform the
industry
one of the first companies we funded is
called cellscope the team came out of a
microscopy lab in berkeley in 2011
they developed a hardware gadget that
sits over the camera on a smartphone
and turns it into an otoscope so this
means that parents can diagnose an ear
infection
at home they can take diagnostic quality
ear images
to detect something that normally would
have to be done through a doctor's
office imagine not many of you have
children but ear infections are the
number one reason for doctors visits
uh with kids and here's the thing
parents usually know when their child
has an ear infection
yet they have to go through the process
of taking the kids
dragging their sick kids to the doctors
for treatment
imagine the time and money saved when
the parents can take the image
actually it's a video from the comfort
of their home at any time of the day
and a doctor can remotely determine if
the child needs antibiotics or not
cellscope raised funding from coastal
ventures and they began shipping product
in december
and all the companies i'm going to tell
you about today are hiring
i don't know if you guys know this but
uh benadryl at a hospital cost eight
hundred dollars
um one of our companies kit check is
automating hospital pharmacies and
trying to reduce the overall cost of
medicine
entrepreneurs kevin and tim came to rock
health in 2012.
kevin worked at sun where he brought
java and rfid to market and he went to
college with tim who's a software
developer
they were having dinner with a friend
who's a hospital pharmacist so this is a
pharmacist that's embedded within the
hospital instead of working at walgreens
or cvs
and she was complaining that she had to
check she had to manually check
each set of medications for a procedure
this simple
conversation about a simple pain point
in the system for
one pharmacist inspired kevin and tim to
start this company kit check
that digitizes the inventory tracking
for a hospital setting
so the first use case is an emergency
kits basically inside a hospital
on each floor or in multiple multiple
places on the floor there's a crash
cart that's used in emergencies on the
card is a small tray of vials
crammed with about 80 life-saving
medications
and if someone crashes a button is
pushed the card is wheeled over
and a doctor looks for what they need
and hopefully picks the medicine that
will save the patient's life
so the cart now has 79 drugs and needs
to be taken back to the central pharmacy
where the medicine is restocked and if i
had a picture of one of these kits with
the 79
medications with one vial missing i
promise you would not be able to find
the missing one
it takes time and manual effort and
hospitals have dozens of people on staff
that are just checking for missing
medications
expired drugs or potentially mislabeled
biles
kevin and tim were consistent
kevin and tim knew there was a better
way so they developed a solution
they tag every medicine in a kit with an
rfid
and they use a scanning station in cloud
software so a hospital can see
its entire inventory in seconds and know
which kits
may have expired or missing medicine
automating this
manual labor intensive checking process
saves time and money
and last i heard from kevin over 100
medical errors
are provided every day using their
product they raised 10.5 million last
year in venture funding and now have
dozens of hospitals that are using their
product
the last company i want to talk about is
called neurotrak it's a completely
software-based alzheimer's diagnostic
they came to rock health in the summer
of 2012 after completing an nih trial
at emory university
and they ended up following the patients
in the trial for an additional two years
and they found that the software could
predict alzheimer's three to six years
earlier
than the status quo neurotrax
diagnostics it's not a biomarker
it's not a genetic test it's an eye
tracking test take it on a computer
using software it takes less than seven
minutes and requires no specialized
training
you don't have to download anything um
it is based on innate human preference
for novelty and with its algorithms can
detect
highly subtle changes in a person's
cognitive function
it's not necessarily the direct to
consumer application that's most
exciting although i'm sure all of you
would be very interested to take the
test
it's really the application in clinical
trials today we have no treatment for
the millions and millions of people
who suffer from this devastating disease
most
experts and researchers will say we have
the molecules we have the targets
it's just impossible to put together the
perfect clinical trial
because you don't know who's going to
get alzheimer's or not
they raised a series a from peter thiel
and the social capital partnership last
year and are now
actively working with pharmaceutical
companies to better
design their clinical trials so we can
find a cure for alzheimer's
so these three companies cell scope kit
check and neurotrack i think are great
examples of entrepreneurs
mostly from outside of healthcare today
that are using technology to transform
healthcare
these tools really allow us to be high
resolution
in our understanding of the patient they
move us from a reactive system
to a preventative model which saves
money and lives
our current system is hospital-centric
and doctor-dependent
but with technology we can move care out
of the hospital walls and into our homes
and our daily lives
technology allows a team of caregivers
to communicate and collaborate on a
healthy
on the health of a child or elderly
family member
and perhaps most importantly technology
can empower
all of us to take health care into our
own hands and be more proactive
all these things are changing healthcare
as we know it so what's this all about
it's not about eliminating doctors it
really isn't any doctors in the room
i piss off a lot of doctors it's really
not about
replacing doctors if we look at what we
call the healthcare supply stack the
chain of specialists generalists
nurses lay people and we can just move
the diagnosis from inside the
very expensive healthcare into the
patient's hands
just cascade it downwards for the things
that are more routine like ear
infections
things can be diagnosed with ubiquitous
software and sensors
and we have this amazing opportunity to
free up capacity in the system
then doctors can focus on the most
complex cases
and coordinating care for the highest
risk patients
imagine if today every woman needed to
go to the doctors to get a pregnancy
test
or if we had to see a specialist to get
a strep strep throat diagnosis
it pulls an incredible amount of cost
out of the system
we all interact with the very costly
system less and we free up our capacity
to focus on the most complex cases
healthcare is broken as i mentioned
earlier we have the most expensive
system in the world
yet our outcomes and quality are no
better and often worse than other
developed nations
we all know that modern technology has
the power to lower costs and make health
care
better for everyone yet the use of
technology and health care is minimal
over the last 20 years while the general
economy
has seen labor productivity gains of 1.8
percent per year
productivity in the health care industry
has declined
we need more people today than we needed
20 years ago
and we get no better output from it
healthcare is the single largest
opportunity today to create lasting
value for our health and human happiness
and i hope that as you guys think of
your career moves after stanford
you consider bringing your talents to
healthcare thank you
so i forgot to say that she
is one of cnn's 12 entrepreneurs
reinventing healthcare i think you just
see why or someone or in forbes
30 under 30. did you win the golden
globe the other day too yeah
did you miss it yeah um
that was something else and thank you
for uh helping us start this off you
know our format is to open up the
for q a and we'll do that in a few
minutes our team had a few questions
though
softballs i promise so let's can we talk
about rock health a little bit and
how many companies are being incubated
or accelerated there right now
uh well we have almost 60 companies in
their portfolio so
so and we have in the office at one time
we'll have
12 companies okay and how do you select
them
so we have a bunch of partners from
industry and well one of the fortunate
things from being outside of healthcare
coming into healthcare was that
i knew i didn't know anything and i was
able to bring together a lot of really
smart people from across the healthcare
system
all the stakeholders we work with top
hospitals we work with
a lot of the corporates the distributors
the vcs
and so we really lean on our partners to
help us um
take weeks to receive what's the primary
reason they agreed to
to get involved um i'm speaking of
incentives
yeah uh it depends on what kind of
partners i mean the large healthcare
companies
uh their industry is changing so rapidly
i mean the
with the aca obamacare there are a lot
of changes
um for payers for instance the insurance
companies have
new regulations that are changing their
businesses pharma companies are
having a really hard time with r d right
now so all these companies are investing
in innovation
and learning um from how technology can
be applied to health care so it's really
hard for them to hire great
technologists
to be honest and probably very few of
you have dreams of going and working at
aetna but they you know need to really
bring talented people in so they're
looking to work
alongside entrepreneurs with great
technologists that have
better products versus building them
themselves
um can we talk a little bit about your
career
before we open up so um
but that's connected to rock health
first so you came up with this idea as a
as a second year harvard school it was
between my first and second year
and and it came to you and so how what's
what was that like to
germinate an idea yeah because some
people are doing that yeah how many
people have ideas now
yeah well you know i think a lot about
what was
you know because you kind of have
rose-colored glasses on when i look back
and it's like oh yeah i always knew it
was going to work out but to be honest i
mean they're
a good six months that i was you know
talking to my husband every night crying
thinking it wasn't gonna work out
um because there's there's a point where
you really have to when you're in school
you can kind of toy around
and work as though it's gonna happen but
then you have the safety net of if it
doesn't happen
you graduate and get a real job so being
a student is a great time to start a
company it's totally de-risked for you
um but there is a point where you're
coming upon graduation
and you have to decide really to jump in
or not um
and i got a lot of positive signals from
early supporters of rock health
including the mayo clinic which was kind
of our first partner
um but it really um
there were probably a good six months
where i didn't think i was able to pull
it together and you just have to kind of
pretend like it's going to work out
and fool everyone into following you um
yeah we hear this over you know this
because there is in all
of the courses we hear this notion of
tenacity over and over again and that
that's still the case even in this
generation of entrepreneurs
i remember in meeting you at that
harvard business school advisory
council out here you had just been
flying doing red eyes every week
yeah or something like that for months
yeah something like that
yeah um so that that was grad school
though
so going back you worked at intel and
apple i mean two technology giants so
those are but they're big companies um
what experiences or skills from working
there
are you using now that's a good question
as you know as a ceo you know i would
say there's just this like
learning how to work it's just so
different from school
having to just do the same thing day in
and day out and having
a manager that you have to keep happy
and understanding politics within a
workplace
so there are those kind of soft skills
that you don't you don't learn in school
at
all um you know learning how to sell i
think that's a really
i actually never even learned that intel
i learned that when i worked at
nordstrom
um in college but learning to sell is
like one of the best
skills you can have like it just pays so
well
and as an entrepreneur if you can sell
you're always selling you're selling
new employees you're selling investors
you're selling your customers
and if you can learn how to understand
customers and serve customers
and you can learn that at a low stakes
job at starbucks or
in retail i would suggest doing that
because that was probably where i
learned the most
yeah so i heidi i don't know if you have
and i should have mentioned you earlier
heidi rosen is here and she is teaching
the course that takes place after this
course i know a lot of you here
to take the course for one unit but you
ought to consider msne 178 sometime
because
what happens after this and i'm just
saying this for folks who are new to
this
uh is another course that adds on to a
couple more units do you have any
questions
heidi i'm just i'm really curious about
so you have a small fund and so
you need to have other investors follow
on that sort of
yeah you need to engage with other
people and health care is
i was just with a group of vcs last
night giving advice to some new vcs and
one of them said oh
do not invest in health care right i
mean just like it's
it's a terrible space it's a you know
it's it's it's front and the fda is
terrible and all of a sudden yeah
and so how do you line these companies
up and how do you think about
that in terms of what you fund yeah
because there's sort of this chasm
to get them through without more
traditional funding
it's a good question we really align
ourselves with large vcs i mean kleiner
perkins is
is one of our investors and so we try to
align ourselves with finding ideas that
are not just appealing for a seed
investor but would be really appealing
for
for you know vcs that need to see huge
huge exits and that helps us
also think really big so we can just be
like you know go big or go home there
are a lot of
uh you know there there are a lot of
deals that
might exit for 10 to 20 million and
that's a really good investment if
you've done 100k
but we try to focus on deals that can
then go get venture funding
and either lead to an ipo or a really
large exit
for example do you do you lean towards
companies where the consumer is paying
the bill as opposed to the insurance
company do you lean towards things that
don't need fda approval
i mean are there sort of known potholes
in the healthcare road that right now
you're saying
we're not heading towards those or you
take some of that on as well
yeah so um things that there are a
couple of things that we do like so if
something already has a reimbursement
code
so there the insurance companies are
already paying
other people for that same uh tool then
if a company can come in and do that
digitally
and have it be much lower cost then it's
able to scale
we have a company that is taking a known
therapy for pre-diabetics
that is reimbursed and it's actually an
in-person class that insurance pays for
people to go to the hospital to take
these classes and they're just bringing
it online and so there's already
reimbursement code they already know
that they can fit into the system
and they can do it at a much lower cost
and make it a lot easier for patients to
do because they don't have to go into
the hospital every time
there's a lot in hospital administration
and it's not very sexy but there's a lot
of money
for hospitals to be able to deploy
better tools that can help them make
decisions the ehr landscape is one of
the biggest
industries within healthcare right now
being able to as
kit check i think was a really great
example automate some processes that are
traditionally done on pen and paper
so hospitals have a lot of
great needs that aren't really being
addressed by the
incumbents the the legacy healthcare
technology companies
are the bar is so low i encourage all of
you guys to go look at the software
that's being built by the big
healthcare it companies and you will be
like i can build that better
for my dorm room i can build that better
um because the the status quo for the
technology is just so
crappy well that then that makes me
think of the last question before we
open it up
uh there's this thing called the
affordable care act
yeah and it's it's even been renamed
into obamacare yeah so our department
which sponsors this as well the
management science and engineering
department prides itself in teaching
technology and entrepreneurship but also
policy so can we talk a little bit about
obamacare
i'm confused yeah i don't know what i
really i don't know what to think about
it anymore
so i mean i would think you from your
vantage point
and everything we've heard about what's
happening in rock health i mean what's
happening
yeah well what they're a bunch of things
are happening um
one is really around insurance reform so
insurers
now the health exchange so they're
starting to compete on a marketplace so
they're not just competing based on who
your employer is
but there are 30 million new people who
are going to get insurance that did not
have insurance before
and insurers are going to have to
compete based on quality so they're
adding services
to differentiate their products from
others and so we're starting to see them
really invest
in greater tools for their population
we're also seeing new health insurance
companies pop up i don't know if you
guys have heard of oscar
in new york but a classmate of mine from
hbs was like
i could do this better he's i mean he's
like a he's a tech investor he invested
in
in in instagram and boss do and he's
like
you know i want to start a new health
insurance company that's better than
anything out there
that people can email us and we can have
better service and we have lower
infrastructure
costs because we don't have this legacy
group people we have to ensure
so that's one piece of the affordable
care act that i think is making a big
difference
um i mean another thing that i you know
i talk a lot i talked a lot about
how we pay for health care and how right
now we pay for volume rather than
outcomes
but one of the things that is changing
is around the way we pay for health care
and there are things being set up called
accountable care organizations acos you
guys might have read about them
but they're really new financial
instruments for providers
that enable them to get paid based on
caring for patients
as a group so the incentives are
restructured so that they have teams of
care coordinators that are taking care
of a patient
instead of having you go see 15
specialists if you have some chronic
disease
all right well you've been so patient so
i'm
going to give it to give it to you you
have any further questions for her
yeah a number of rock house like
portfolio companies um
involve like data infrastructure data
analysis and you want to know
what you see as data's role in health
care in the next few years
yeah which talk about big data yeah well
i think there
are two really great applications for
data one is on the research side of
things
so enabling researchers to share data
across
academic institutions that would usually
silo their data instead kind of sharing
across we have a company
called cancer iq that's doing that with
cancer data they came out of university
of chicago
and wanted to enable every
community researcher to have the same
sort of data that a large cancer center
would have
so if you're a small researcher you
probably only see
a few rare cases you don't have enough
data to actually do research on that
instead they're
able to kind of combine it across
institutions
so one place would be around research
and then the other is point of care
so when you're actually receiving care
from a provider the more data they have
on your ex who you are your genomic data
your clinical history
they're able to use that information and
making clinical decisions
um so a lot of hospitals are starting to
invest in the genomics space
so that they have they know you as a
human and not just your medical records
but uh if you're if you have brocco one
you're more likely to get breast cancer
they might have you
test for breast cancer earlier since
you're more likely to get it et cetera
so we're making decisions
we call this precision medicine
personalized medicine you guys might
have heard that term
but it's really using everything that we
have as data to make sure that every
every person isn't isn't um just the
average we don't just look at like on
average
people get cancer at this age but given
what we know about you
when are you going to get most likely to
get cancer and how can we avoid that
ally can you repeat the question for the
live audience just in case
oh yes so the question was about how um
how data big data is being used in
healthcare
yes so thank you for painting such an
inspiring vision about revolutionizing
healthcare
are you ready to start a healthcare
company hopefully but you also
explain how broken the system was yeah
so we talked a lot about the
opportunities entrepreneurs have but
what are the challenges that they're
facing right now
um i don't want to discourage you uh so
i'm not going to tell the worst no
um there are a lot of challenges um for
entrepreneurs in healthcare
and they're really changing i would say
three years ago
when i started this the problem was
getting funding so
there weren't a lot of investors that
were comfortable with both the
technology aspect and the healthcare
aspect
traditional vc is divided between life
science that has
traditionally been therapeutics and
devices and technology that's
generally been consumer web or
enterprise
and this kind of intersection there are
a few vcs three years ago that were
focused on it
there were a couple of vcs that were
well positioned because they had
people in both areas so vcs like kleiner
and nea that have both a life science
practice and uh tech practice were able
to move really fast
so i'd say three years ago it was
funding but since i started this
in 2011 funding venture funding in the
space has more than doubled
so we've seen this year
i think it was almost two billion
dollars that was invested in digital
health which is really exciting
um and funding is no longer a problem i
don't think
our entrepreneurs have raised over 100
million and
follow on funding so they're they're
definitely getting funded not all of
them but you know
a lot of them are getting funded and i
think the problems the biggest problems
now
um are really around how fragmented the
system is
and if you're selling to a hospital if
you're selling to
even insurer whoever your customer is
there are
thousands of them and you have to go out
and build a sales team to
to really go sell those customers so um
i think that would be probably the most
challenging on the
enterprise side and then on the consumer
side i mentioned
in my talk that we only pay for 12 of
our health care we don't like paying for
things we're cheap when it comes to
health care
we want someone else to pay and so
coming up with business models
that rely on having the consumers pay
for things is really challenging
so you have to figure out where the
value is being added so maybe
the consumer doesn't pay but you're
adding you're keeping the consumer
healthy so that the insurance company
doesn't have to pay for something down
the road so maybe you can convince the
insurance company to pay for it
probably not but maybe or employers
maybe an employer would pay for it since
it's
more wellness oriented um so i think the
business model
part is is a big challenge for
entrepreneurs but it's not
insurmountable
yeah how does uh rockhealth
differentiate itself from other
incubators in space like starbucks
manager or health fast yeah
so we're we're not an incubator anymore
we're full service seed funds so we
started out as an incubator we were
at the 20 000 investment level um and
then
we kind of evolved to become more of a
seed investor because we knew that the
companies
needed to to have a little more funding
than twenty thousand so we give a
hundred thousand
um so we're kind of in in between
incubators and venture funds
and i would say uh we're very
complementary to we've had companies go
through stardex
and rockhealth we've had a ton of
companies go through yc and rockhealth
um and so we see ourselves as very
complimentary and it's great to see all
these
places that are trying to support
entrepreneurs it's a good thing for us
yeah back there uh you talked a lot at
the beginning about
uh preventive health i know you have a
lot of health and wellness and fitness
uh digital technologies in your
portfolio yeah you talk about the
opportunity you see in that part of the
market
yeah i mean well wellness is a 36
billion dollar market
um and consumers have for a very long
time
paid for things like supplements gym
memberships
things that kind of keep us healthy the
diet industry is huge as you know
so that's kind of a market that already
exists and digitizing it is a really
interesting opportunity we have a couple
companies that are in the space i'll
just give one example
of a stanford company called wello
and they're basically creating an online
platform for trainers to meet virtually
with
um with anyone who wants a personal
trainer but can't afford to have one at
the gym
and because it's online it's cheaper you
can do it at your at home
if you're on the road a lot you can stay
with your trainer you don't have to
actually go into the gym
and trainers who are usually really busy
before work and after work so they're
usually busy between like six and eight
am
and five and seven pm and then the day
they're kind of you know
at a loss of what to do they're actually
connecting people with trainers that are
in different
um time zones so they might be in new
york and you're in san francisco
and so they have a lot of downtime and
they'll take a client virtually for a
lot less
because they want to fill their time so
they're bringing down the cost
of having a personal trainer and getting
fit and they're increasing access for
all of us
and that's you know in the wellness in
the wellness space i'm really excited
about what they're doing
now one more one more stanford we have a
lot of stanford companies uh i'll i'll
plug one more aspire and these are guys
all of them are hiring so
if you guys are looking for internships
or jobs um
spire is a really interesting um
quantified
self tool it's a gadget that sits right
here on your belt
and it monitors your breathing so they
did a
trial with linkedin to see if linkedin
employees would wear it if they could
tell you when you're getting really
stressed out and when you're breathing
heavily
if they can help employees stay calm and
be more productive
and so they're going to be starting a
kickstarter campaign in the next few
months look out for them
but they came out of the calming tech
lab i don't know if you guys know the
time coming tech lab
but they're a really cool team working
on an important thing in the wellness
space
yeah uh you mentioned a lot of the
advantages of digital health
like the fact that i can provide ease of
access to health care it can make it
cheaper
yeah what do you think are some of the
disadvantages of medicine progressing
towards digital health like do you think
it
presents to you like practicing
challenges or security challenges or
what would you say to critics who say
that like digital health is kind of
commodifying health care
and removing like the typical the
traditional uh patient physician
relationship
yeah um well you know doctors are
spending a lot of their time with their
backs towards their patients
typing into the emr system and that's a
complaint that
you know is very loud and clear in the
system i don't know if any of you guys
have experienced that
so there are ways that technology has
kind of distracted
providers from what's really the task at
hand it's caring for an individual in
that one-on-one relationship
and i think that that's that that's a
problem um
however having that information
digitally and not have and having kind
of a record
is the price i mean that's the price you
pay to have kind of
uh your information stored so there are
definitely pros and cons um
but it's also again like a cultural it's
a cultural thing
these are not necessarily technology
problems they're you know
why don't we rethink why aren't we using
ipads then because you know you can
really use an ipad while looking
somewhat looking at someone in the in
the eyes
but it's a good question i think that i
obviously believe there are more
benefits
than cons of using technology within the
system but we have to be really aware of
the pitfalls
yeah when you think about a moment of
informed consent
through procedures in hospital
and empowering the patient have you seen
any
apps come forward that instead of
empowering the docs
and hospitals repairing patients at that
moment
could you repeat the question yeah so
the question was
um have i had have i seen any tools that
enable informed consent at the point of
care um
and i don't know if i have so are you
working on something like that
what's the name
some students over here yeah so you
mentioned that
one of the difficulties in the
healthcare space is that especially as
compared to
traditional vc roles in tech um
healthcare is much more highly regulated
we saw that recently with the fda
cracking down on 23andme yeah
so how do you do you think that you
offer sort of expertise with companies
in sort of navigating that or do you
just as you say sort of like five niches
that are already accepted
and better yeah so there are a couple so
the question was around
the regulatory burden on entrepreneurs
and how
uh my organization kind of supports
entrepreneurs for that process
um so i mean just today we had the cto
of hhs
so health and human services in our
office talking to our entrepreneurs
about
um what they're working on so just being
able to kind of bring someone in and
talk to many people at once is really
helpful
um you know we've never been
afraid of the fda in a lot of ways i
think of the fda as a competitive
advantage because if you can get fda
approval like cell scope they got fda
approval
it takes your competitors that much
longer to get to that point
and the fda really is around to protect
patients
and um you know we we've met with them
and we know that
their intent is to protect patients so
as long as there is a clear process
for getting fda approval then i think
that's a fair thing that we have in our
society
i think where it gets challenging is
when
it's unclear that that process is
unclear
and there is a lot of uncertainty around
the mobile health guidelines and so if
you put a
so medical devices have long been
regulated by the fda
if you claim to treat or diagnose
anything you have to get approved by the
fda
so the million dollar question is if you
put an app a healthcare app
on your smartphone does that turn your
smartphone into a medical device
and does that app need to be regulated
and for a long time we didn't you know
we still don't
quite know what the fda is going to do
but they're starting to put out
guidelines and for me i'd rather have
very clear guidelines of what's
regulated and what's not than ambiguity
because that's when
entrepreneurs step back and say well i'm
not going to invest in building this
because i don't know if the fda is going
to come down on me
but when we have kind of clear processes
and an understanding
and a process that's not too expensive
then i think it's
it's something that is necessary in
society
i hope that answered the question okay
um i see a hand in the back yeah uh do
you
measure success with other metrics
besides financial returns and
can you answer your choice on whether
you do or not yeah
we actually had is elise in the room we
had an
awesome stanford mba intern uh last
summer
that helped us we called it our impact
project
and we wanted we wanted better ways to
measure
the success of our companies than
follow-on funding
and number of employees those are like
that's like low-hanging fruit that's
really easy to measure
um but it doesn't necessarily tell us
what kind of impact we're making on
healthcare in the healthcare space
so um we had elise it was gsbr come in
for the summer and really help us devise
a survey for all of our entrepreneurs
that put them in different buckets based
on
what they were trying to accomplish
because you can imagine it's not apples
to apples
one company might be looking at how many
pounds were lost using their app another
company might be trying to reduce
medication errors like kit check and so
we were able to come up with
a series of impact metrics that we
wanted to measure
and we gave each of our companies a way
to
report on those metrics so we said you
know because you're working on this tool
we expect you to tell us how many
patients have used your tool how many
doctors have used it how many
lives have been saved by you know
triangulating from all that other data
and so it is very important to us it's
very challenging
um just because our companies are all so
different that there's not like
one number that would say the impact
that we're making on the health care
system
but rather many numbers and if you go to
our website
now we're featuring our annual report on
our home page and that's where we
released a lot of this data of the
outcomes of our companies
yeah um i talked in the beginning about
the 2.7 trillion dollars that we spent
each year
on the healthcare system and that we
know you know with charge masters that
we're being loaded
um these costs and if we move towards a
more efficient healthcare system in
america to be
comparable to everyone else in these um
developed countries
wouldn't that in a sense shrink the
marketplace of what we want through
policy and through competitive
pricing when that stuff kind of um
interesting yeah
how are you addressing iraq the yeah the
future
so the question is you know some of the
if we fix some of the problems of prices
being too high
and outcomes not being high are we
actually if if we
solve that are we shrinking the market
that we're working in
and is that becoming less it's actually
a very good question i've never thought
about it that way
but i had a professor that once said to
me in business school where
where there's waste there's opportunity
and there's so much waste in the
healthcare system we spend
so much money that is going uh that is
not going to help us
get healthier it's not going to helping
people who are uninsured get insured
there's just a ton of waste in the
system and so i don't think that
i think by reducing the waste we kind of
even out um
other aspects that are beneficial to us
um
and that it's like we don't want the
health care system to be
so so big it's not a good thing
yeah yeah you talked about our health
care system not being good as
others around the world have you heard
of any solutions for like
health tourism or global race yeah
yeah we actually have seen a lot of
interesting companies that are
um addressing medical tourism we we
actually haven't
worked with any companies in that space
we have
some ethical concerns around um pointing
people towards providers
that you can't necessarily vet and that
don't have to go
through the same sort of rigor as the
the physicians here
in the u.s so ultimately it's a space
that's like very intriguing but
um for like what procedures the one that
we saw was
um a lot of like elective cosmetic
procedures and that just wasn't a
business that we were excited about
um but i think it's a it's ripe for
opportunity
so you should start that company let's
do one more
oh spend it my way let's do one
one more one more one more yeah a good
one yeah
okay so i mean in order to uh decrease
the healthcare costs i mean one has to
focus on the preventive side right
but i mean um one problem with the
prevention is that there isn't a whole
lot of money and then issues
are not really working okay yeah so it
gets really kind of a
problem so i mean what what do you think
about that i mean
especially in the long term yeah what's
your take on that
yeah no it's a great question because
when
anything that's kind of preventative so
when you're saying you're going to
prevent someone from having a heart
attack or prevent them from having
diabetes
it's like this promised value in some
future
date like we're going to save you money
down the road but who actually wants to
pay for that
um and the only answer is who's paying
for it who would be paying for it
instead of you which is the insurers and
so they're the ones that are really
focused on
being able to prevent anything that will
cost them a lot down the road
the problem is we switch employers and
we switch insurers all the time
um and so the insurance companies also
have their actuaries that are doing
the math on it and you know it
they might be preventing something that
another insurer will have to pay for
down the road so there are a lot of
questions there
that's a good question all right thank
you so much
you